[موسيقى]
مفتاح صناعة الأغذية
والمشروبات هو كونها فريدة من نوعها، لذلك نحن
نعلم أن دبي تتمتع بالفخامة العالية وأنهم
يحبون الأشياء المجنونة في دبي، لذلك أردنا
أن نظهر لهم ما يريدون ونحن
سعداء حقًا لأن ضيوفنا أحبوا
ذلك،
حسنًا
فكرة القهوة تأتي من الأصدقاء
بالطبع الناس يحبون قهوة
الكابتشينو والكثير منها إلى الكرواسون،
فلماذا لا تكون كبيرة مثل
الكرواسون الذي
نعيشه في عوالم وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي،
أنشأنا مقطع فيديو وانتشر على نطاق واسع
نحن سعداء حقًا لأننا لم
نعبر مكانًا ما فحسب، بل نحن
سعداء حقًا لأننا في القمة على هذا
المسرح في دبي [
موسيقى]
للكرواسون فقط والقهوة العملاقة التي
يحب الناس تصويرها ويحبون
المنشور  لذا، أولاً وقبل كل شيء، هم
المدونون المؤثرون، والمتحدثون عن الشاي، من
الجيل الجديد، لذا فهم يطالبون حقًا
بالكرواسون والقهوة العملاقة
هاهاها [
تصفيق]
وهذه الملابس مصنوعة بالحب،
فلماذا كنا نستعد للمناقشة، لقد
قمنا باختبار هذا أكثر من 100 مرة
هي وصفتنا السرية ولكن بالطبع
نستخدم Fallout قياسي محمي بأشعة الشمس
ولكن أيضًا مكونات سرية على طراز البوهو
بداخلها،
رأى البعض منهم الانزعاج لكي نكون صادقين، فهم
يعتقدون أنهم يهدرون
الطعام لكنهم ينسون أن لدينا
وجبة جاهزة،
لذا أيًا كان ما تريد  لا نستهلك
نحن نخدم لمنزلك
[موسيقى]